If you remember our discussion
from a long time ago, we said
that much of this class consists
of variations of a
few basic skills and ideas,
one of which is the Bayes
rule, the foundation
of inference.
So let's look here at the
Bayes rule again and its
different incarnations.
In a discrete setting we have a
random variable with a known
PMF but whose values
are not observed.
Instead we observe the value
of another random variable,
call it Y, which has some
relation with X.
And we will use the value of Y
to make some inferences about
X. The relation between the
two random variables is
captured by specifying the
conditional PMF of Y given any
value of X. Think of X as an
unknown state of the world and
of Y as a noisy observation of
X. The conditional PMF tells
us the distribution of
Y under each possible
state of the world.
Once we observe the value of Y
we obtain some information
about X. And we use this
information to make inferences
about the likely values of X.
Mathematically, instead of
relying on the prior for X, we
form some revised beliefs.
That is, we form the
conditional [PMF]
of X given the particular
observation that we have seen.
All this becomes possible
because of the Bayes rule.
We have seen the Bayes
rule for events.
But it is easy to translate
into PMF notation.
We take the multiplication
rule.
And we use it twice in different
orders to get two
different forms--
or two different expressions--
for the joint PMF.
We then take one of the terms
involved here and send it to
the other side.
We obtain this expression,
which is the Bayes rule.
What [do] we have here?
We want to calculate the
conditional distribution of X
which we typically call
the posterior.
And to do this we rely on the
prior of X as well as on the
model that we have for
the observations.
The denominator requires us to
compute the marginal of Y. But
this is something that is easily
done because we have
the joint available.
The numerator, this expression
here, is just the joint PMF.
And using the joint PMF
you can always find
the marginal PMF.
Essentially, we're using here
the total probability theorem.
And we're using the pieces of
information that were given to
us, the prior and the model
of the observations.
When we're dealing with
continuous random variables
the story is identical.
We still have two versions of
the multiplication rule.
By sending one term--
this term--
to the other side of
the equation we
get the Bayes rule.
And then we use the total
probability theorem to
calculate the denominator
term.
So as far as mathematics go,
the story is pretty simple.
It is exactly the same
in the discrete and
the continuous case.
This story will be our stepping
stone for dealing
with more complex models and
also when we go into more
detail on the subject
of inference
later in this course.